the order is translated in a day, after a
comprehensive assessment of the current situation, it is
proposed to take up defense
along the left bank of the Dnieper River,
I understand that this is a very difficult decision,
at the same time
we will save the most important thing is the life of our
military personnel
and, in general, the combat capability of the group of
troops
to keep which on the right bank in a
limited area is
unpromising, in addition
part of the forces and means will
be released which will be from Odessa
for active operations, including
offensive order in other
directions in the operation zone,
proceed to this troops and take all
measures to ensure the safe
transfer of personnel weapons and
equipment
[music]
We will see that for now Time will tell so
you say now in advance that we’ll be back, we won’t be
back, you know It’s difficult
Although, of course, at our age, the
bulk of it is already clear that
[music]
in these conditions, the city of Kherson and the
nearby settlements cannot be
fully supplied with the
life of people for the shelling of the village  constantly
endangered the
enemy conducts indiscriminate
shooting at the city, possibly with
prohibited methods of warfare